okay
maybe
uh
or in general
[Music]
but it was like really time consuming
like three or four hours a day
to do that so
that was kind of enduring yeah so that
right
these different um
it's
um
i love it so much
oh no it's great i love it i mean it's
it does everything
um
whatever
um
so
good afternoon my name is reverend kevin
mccall
civil rights leader founder of the
crisis action center
we're joined by terry floyd the brother
of
george floyd
gwen carl the mother of eric garner
and attorney sanford rubinstein
we are here today to
mark the road
the continual road of justice
this road started when myself
and terence and tony rubenstein and
others
took the trip to minnesota
to call for justice and to call for
peace
this is a continual journey that we must
continue to raise our voice
and be heard millions of people across
the country
of the usa and other countries
heard the rallying cry of
justice for george floyd
and now we had a pivotal moment
where the trial has started
and we know that people have
different emotions and different aspects
about what
should folks expect about what should
ex happen
but we believing in god that justice
would prevail
we believe in those peaceful protesters
that continue to raise their voice and
streaming
no justice no peace we've been dealing
with it
last may
and we're going to be dealing with it in
this month
we are hopeful and prayerful that the
system that
they tell us to believe in will work for
us
we are prayerful that the system
that they told us to be able to wait and
let it work for us
that justice will reign we're prayerful
for that
and we want to say that those who
want to protest that they continue
to protest but do it peace
don't loot don't do
the things of destruction do it
in peace we'll be
going down to minnesota minneapolis
on march the 27th after the jewish
election
and will be down there calling for
justice
and monitoring and support
of the floyd family
terrence will be inside the courtroom
once
the alternate family member will take
the rightful place inside the courtroom
because that's what justice does is stay
on top of the case
not just when it's hot but when it's
nothing is happening
and we want to make sure
that officer former officer chauvin
be held responsible to the fullest
extent of the law
that's what we're praying for that's
what we're
hoping for that's what we're believing
for
at this time you will hear from terry
floyd
the brother of george floyd
peace everybody peace
first and foremost i want to thank
everyone for the love
that you've shown my family in this
giant child
basically it's uh
it's kind of surreal right now but we
have to
basically relive this whole situation
all over again
uh but by the help of god
and my circle that's around me reverend
mccoy
uh david wright um
we go i'm gonna get through this i'm
gonna help my family get through this
uh like i said i'll be down here
for this case and i'm praying and hoping
for the outcome that we all want
but you know in reality i'm gonna say
if it don't go that way i just know and
believe in my heart
that it's going to be changed regardless
for us
as a nation thank you
the mother of eric garner one car
good afternoon everyone i
stand here in solidarity with this
family
as i did from the very beginning
this case it touched my heart so
personally
um as george floyd said that he couldn't
breathe my son said he couldn't breathe
11 times 11 times my son said he
couldn't breathe
and that this concerned officer did not
let him live
and as we go forward with this case i
hope
i pray that it's not a lingering case
like my case was
it's almost seven years now and we only
got
one drop of justice one police officer
was fired from the force
there was no criminal charges at least
with this case they did
public officers expediently
so i hope that they continue to do the
right thing down
in minnesota because we see they did not
do the right thing here in new york
in my case i
talked to the family right after this
tragic incident happened and i
told them even though they they fired
the officers
even though that they did the right
thing in the beginning don't think that
this is a slam
dunk because we know once you get in
court they try to
assassinate the victim again
first they murder him they assassinate
him
on the street then they want to
assassinate the character
and you know we just need a justice
system
that is true that is fair
to all people not just some
so let's hope down in minnesota
um when the family is in the courtroom
they show more respect to them than they
show to us
in this courtroom and again i stand with
this family as i did from the beginning
thank you
attorney sanford rubincy
the journey for justice continues in
minnesota
and as a lawyer here in new york who has
represented over 20 families
who have lost loved ones to police
violence
simply this until police services are
put
in jail for wrongfully killing
innocent victims the pandemic of police
brutality
will not end and while we call for peace
on the left
and justice on the right we call for a
conviction
and a long jail sentence for this police
officer
and his associates who will be tried
after him
for the wrongful acts the criminal acts
they have committed
the concern that i have
is that we've been down this road before
where we wait patiently we march
peacefully we protest
and then we don't get the right for
justice such as cases like brianna
taylor
if they say believe in the system let
the system work for you
this is an opportunity to show america
to believe in the system again
so while you in that courtroom
make this about justice make this about
that officer who did a criminal act live
right in front of the whole world to see
make that the case
and then that's when we'll be satisfied
that's when
we see what true justice look like
but we can't go down the same path of
just fighting and protesters and
streaming no justice for peace and the
justice system don't work for us
before we close we're going to take
questions but we're going to
close out in prayer because we believe
prayer can change things
we believe that sincere prayer can
change things and
we need to be able to continue to have
prayer at the forefront
of what we do so we're calling on all
clergy
as this trial starts to take an
hour out of your day we call on all
people across the country
take an hour at 12 noon
and pray for justice pray
that for the family because they're
going to need this strength
any question
thank you very much pastor david wright
will be doing the prayer
father god we pray right now
right now we pray for peace on the left
and justice on the right we pray right
now that you strengthen this family
the entire family of george floyd
because even dude through this trial
they'll still have memories of those
horrible nine minutes but god we pray
that you give them
strength strength to deal with this
trial
strength to show strong faith in you
god we need you like never before and
whatever
comes out from this god let there be
peace in the streets
let there be peaceful protests whatever
comes from this god
let no harm come to anybody in the
mighty name of jesus
continue to keep our community safe
continue to keep our leadership safe
continue to strengthen everybody that's
involved with this justice movement
and we decree and declare that we will
have justice for mr george floyd
in jesus name we pray amen
move
so
and that's
thank
it
you